hello everyone
Tony decided to take a break from
YouTube and chess
he will scream for tonight and until he
decides what to do in the future
fortnight or chess I'll be taking over
today I will show you a game between
greco from italy and an unknown guy i
heard you call him hoodie guy so in the
owner the hoodie guy i wearing a hoodie
today fun fact about Greco is between ik
considered he was a first professional
chess player he was the first one who
made money by playing chess
it's beautiful thumbs up the game is
played in 1619 in Roman Italy so let's
eat white opens with E for oh sorry
about that
okay black black replies with b6 trying
to develop the pawn on be CERN white
place before taking care of more of the
center this four squares here black
develops his Bishop on b7 and attacks
the pawn on e4 white develops his Bishop
on the tree and protect the pawn on e4
black plays f5 he wants he help player
he has a plan to take the pawn on the g2
and finally take the rook on each one
but White has a better plan
he doesn't matter he takes on f5 black
takes on g2 and at XD h1 rock and that
gives divided the opportunity to make a
beautiful move Queen h5 check the only
way to defend it
it's g6 white takes and black attacks
attacks the D Queen the Queen on Knight
f6
now white decides to don't care about it
about attacking the Queen because he has
made into so let's find it feel free to
pause the video I'll give you a couple
of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations your excellent finder of
mating - for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
it's h7 check black takes the Queen and
Bishop g6 checkmate so that's the game I
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Alexander F&S afanasiev Bruce
Monson Oliver Oliver outbreak take souk
el guineo Palmeri for contribution to my
channel you can see two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
you can show this beautiful game to your
friends in a bar or library or something
think of watching and see you tomorrow